foreign
with my friend the amazing RuPaul hello
should we spill some tea yeah because
we're sipping us
[Applause]
our drinking room okay so Rue we are we
are drinking Roux right now you have a
delicious new line yes sparkling premium
cocktails as well as mocktails Rossi are
you having a cocktail house of love
mocktail right now I don't know
this is good now we're we're having the
we're having the colada right now I'm
having a colada so delicious what made
you want to do this room well you know
with the show we wanted to create many
different levels of the drag race
experience and and of course house of
love uh drinks are an extension of that
feeling you know the consumer let me
just talk business for a minute you know
the consumer wants Tom dollar if they
want the top value for their dollar they
want a good product they want a
lifestyle they want a vernacular they
want an expression they want a community
so so that's what we're doing with all
of these these products you're an
entrepreneur
yeah all right since we're sipping will
you guys spill the tea
um let's say okay let's see a
circumstance oh I don't know
um you know the time you saw something
that you weren't supposed to see oh
spill the tea well the first the first
thing that comes to mind and my mother
is no longer with us so I can say this
but I remember I was home I had a cold
or something and I remember her going
into her bedroom with her gentleman
friend at the time I was of course
um uh bruised for from it for years but
I remember them going into their bedroom
and I thought what is he going to do
with my mama phone
what but I I don't think I was supposed
to see that but I did see I didn't see
that something that I wasn't supposed to
see was um episode two of White Lotus
season two I was supposed to watch it
with my husband and I watched it without
him sorry oh my goodness he's finding
out right now oh Welly all right spill
the tea on have you ever worked with
someone that rubbed Jesus I have you
know this I I once guessed it on um uh
Sabrina the Teenage Witch yes
with the talking cat yes with the
talking cat yeah and the Wardrobe person
there she was not very nice with me
right so I said you know I can't fire
you right now but if I could fire you
you'd be so fired right now
true story oh my God I'm so sorry I'm
going to use that one day I can't fire
you but if I could you would be so fired
it's the best
[Applause]
I remember working with a wardrobe woman
who looked at me and she goes your
breasts they're just so bad
I was like well that's what we're doing
[Applause]
oh
my God
on a time you lied and still haven't
admitted the truth oh I lied to my
friends when they get bad haircuts
because there's nothing you can do about
it right so I say oh it looks cute and
then when it grows out I go you know
what I think I like it longer yeah what
about you well here's the thing you know
I am a diplomat you know I grew up in a
house with warring factors my mother and
my father and I was the Henry Kissinger
of the house right so you know I learned
how to diplomatically get my point
across but without making uh the war any
worse so if something I don't I wouldn't
lie what I would do is I would I would
say well at least you've got your legs
foreign
at least you've got your legs
yeah yeah exactly I beautiful way to
look at it I never thought about it like
that that's how you do it and we think
of when I last slide I don't I don't
ever lie because I can't lie I'm so bad
at it like she's a great actress but she
cannot like FIB no I can't it's like
it's uh like if it like if you asked me
to lie I'm like this no
like it's so off like I can't do it I
don't know I don't lie but I must have
lied I mean everybody tells a white
thing last time I'm sure I'm sure I do
whatever you know with if it's to save
the situation yes you know I feel like
I'm more of a diplomat like I always can
find a Nuance that is not fraudulent and
not hurtful yeah I'm with you I'm Henry
Kissinger too okay all right so spill
the tea on the best or worst kiss you've
ever had I can tell I can tell you my
best kiss ever was on my wedding day
with my husband well it's the best kiss
ever yes but my worst kiss ever was at
Aladdin I was dating Amy it was in
seventh grade my girlfriend and I was
just riveted by Aladdin hello the open
best to everything and she tried to kiss
me and I was like Amy
I can't think of a a worse kiss because
I'm a good kisser you know and it's like
dancing you know people follow your lead
but you know George the man I'm married
to uh he's a very very good he's got
huge lips and he's he's fabulous but
um side note you know I did this uh show
on uh something called um AJ and the
queen yes
well my co-star in there is Josh segarra
and during rehearsals he would kiss in
real life and I wasn't prepared for that
because we haven't seen we have several
scenes where we would kiss and stuff and
during the rehearsals for it with just
the he would kiss in real I I was not
prepared for that yeah yeah I wasn't you
know and he's straight with two kids and
the whole thing you know and uh but he's
a he's a very good kisser uh so would
you be like I just need one more time
because I really want to get it right no
but we were both very nervous even when
the cameras were wrong we're very
nervous for it I was nervous and because
there was all these people oh I know
it's like it's not at all sexy it's like
a lot of people watching and it does and
like not in like a exciting way right
there's a time and a place for voyeurism
for sure but right not there it's very
clinical and like odd I think my best
kiss was my first one of my best kiss
was my very first kiss with my boyfriend
who I was like nine or ten and it was
like the best like seriously to this day
like the just the best kiss it was it
was great have your knees ever buckled
from a kiss
have your knees ever buckled from
anything yeah
[Laughter]
yeah and then I've totally kissed the
guy who like does that oh that's the
word and you're like all you want to do
is like grab their shoulders and be like
oh
don't break you and remake you
we've all had that experience where
you're like hold on a second we're gonna
go back to school you need to relearn
that because yeah nobody wants that why
don't they teach you how to kiss I don't
well then who's going to teach it right
yeah oh there are people who are
qualified to teach it well I love I see
a new franchise for RuPaul yes
at school kissing School Always Been
Kissed okay you said that you're a good
kisser what was your who was your first
kiss you know there was a girl in the
neighborhood she lived across the street
I was about uh nine years old yeah and I
remember it was in our garage and the
other kids in the the neighborhood stood
around us as we kissed wow yeah and they
just sort of watched us be boyfriend and
girlfriend in fact I think you should
there should be three people involved in
in having a baby you know you know what
I mean yeah like Three Men and a Baby
exactly exactly is this
I'm just saying there are we those three
people
would you guys want to see the baby
raised by the three of us
[Applause]
January 11th at 9 00 pm on CBS also
streaming on Paramount plus so much fun
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you